we're going to begin though with two big
stories that could threaten The Fragile
U.S economy Wall Street suffered very
heavy losses yesterday after China's
biggest public protest in decades Shook
Up investors who were worried very
worried about the disruption to Global
Supply chains and here in the United
States a threat of a Railroad Strike yep
a Railroad Strike could disrupt holiday
shipping Big Time President Biden is now
asking Congress to block that
Ouija Jenga is at the White House with
more on this story Ouija good morning a
lot of people very nervous this morning
good morning Gail and rightfully so
because both of these conflicts could
disrupt the supply chain which would
send already high prices soaring even
more and in both cases the White House
is treading carefully trying to make an
impact without interfering especially in
China amid years of mounting tensions
between the U.S and Beijing
the move is rare and risky rebuking the
Chinese government with some protesters
even calling for president Xi Jinping to
step down
stronger police presence has curbed
clashes with protesters over the
country's zero covid policy which the
White House criticized in a statement it
also said that everyone has the right to
peacefully protest but stop short of
offering support to the demonstrators
the president's not going to speak for
protesters around the world they're
speaking for themselves the Biden
Administration is treading cautiously
trying to stabilize relations with
Beijing the unrest in China has already
led to tumbling stocks worldwide
it comes as here at home the president
asked Congress to intervene in a rail
dispute and said a strike would hurl
this nation into a devastating rail
Freight shut down Congress could push
back the strike deadline extend the
negotia cheating period forced the two
sides to use an arbitrator or an act
legislation to adopt an agreement so far
all 12 unions involved have not approved
a contract and workers could walk out
early next month Mark Zandy is the chief
Economist of Moody's Analytics over
one-fourth of all of the goods are
transported by a rail so if the rail
industry is on strike those things just
won't get from report to the store shelf
that will add to shortages both these
issues the rail strike potential rail
strike and what's going on in China
around Supply chains and covid
threatened to make worse the
inflationary problems that we're now
facing
hundreds of businesses sent a letter to
Congressional leaders urging them to get
involved in warning that a rail strike
could cost the U.S economy up to two
billion dollars a day house Speaker
Nancy Pelosi said lawmakers would vote
to impose an agreement this week to
avoid a quote catastrophic strike and
then it'll be up to the Senate Vlad
Ouija thank you very much